we're glad to have the fabulous pamela
geller welcome
hi welcome welcome to the battlefield
welcome to the war what happened today
is not extraordinary what happened today
is not exceptional what happened today
best illustrates what's happening and
why I wrote this book the very idea that
a human rights activist dedicated to
freedom of speech freedom of religion
freedom of conscience and individual
rights would be cancelled by a hotel
that hosts Mahmoud Ahmadinejad whose
promised the annihilation of the tiny
Jewish state of Israel
who entertains at the Hyatt in New York
would cancel me in caving to this
leftist Islamic alliance is indicative
of how very bad the war is worse is how
few are aware of it I mean Americans
know there's something wrong you know
like like the Helen Keller and someone
move the furniture but there is so much
deception there is so much propaganda
there's so much disinformation that that
you need glasses to see what's happening
there is a war on the truth and what is
truth truth is the recognition reality's
a is a and why is it so important to
silence my to silence my voice to
silence Robert Spencer's voice no need
are wheeshes voice ayaan Hirsi Ali Zoe's
waka Sultan's voice because it's
important that the truth be kept from
you and yet all you have to do is look
around and see that this is a war in the
information battle space this is a war
of information and all the bullets and
the bombs and the bloodshed comes as a
result of what happens in this war and
they have in the
the most powerful weapon of all big
media it's the reason why Obama was
elected it's the reason why you don't
know what's happening but I will
describe to you in brief detail the
stealth jihad the masking of the
workplace for example imposing Muslim
prayer times on union contracts forcing
non-muslim workers to lengthen their day
that's wrong that's imposing Islam on
the secular marketplace you have a
company like Heinz the ketchup company
by the way who's been enormously
generous to their Muslim workers not
only do they have Muslim prayer rooms
they have Muslim prayer rugs but they're
being sued why they being sued they're
being sued to stop the line stop the
line for Muslim prayer times now
understand something in Muslim countries
they don't stop the line in Iran they
don't stop during the work day to pray
they pray before work they pray after
work why so why why do I do it here it's
to impose Islam on non-muslims you see
the taxicab drivers that won't pick up
fares that have alcohol that have seen
eye dogs because dogs are dirty dogs are
filthy you see the US Treasury
Department the US Treasury Department
giving seminars in Sharia finance a week
after we nationalize some banks now
you'll say to me what I will show you a
finance Pamela I'm glad you asked me
that question it has to be hello which
means investing in certain industries is
forbidden pork alcohol tobacco and some
forms of entertainment well those are
whole American industries do you want to
use your taxpayer dollars to start whole
American industries there is the masking
of the public schools where they have
press spaces for some children they
don't have it for Christians they don't
have it for Jews they don't have it the
Hindus they don't have it for
zoroastrians there's also the Islamist
sizing of the public school curriculum
where they are instituting whole
curriculum curriculums dedicated to
Islam but not to the 1,400 years of a
270 million victims of jihadi Wars land
appropriations cultural annihilations
Lehman's it's complete Sawa it's
complete whitewashing now I did fault
your governor for this governor perry
instituted along with Agha Khan a
complete and I ran screenshots of all
the lessons don't listen to me judge for
yourself that's another thing you're
going to have to do you're going to have
to do your own homework because you are
being lied to and I don't see
curriculums in the public schools for
Christians I don't see curriculums in
the public schools for Jews or for
anybody else and for those of you that
have children in the school and who see
this who see this and parents see it
look just two weeks ago I was contacted
by a parent and a columnist in the
parent school they had a lesson the
lesson was my name is Ashley MA and I
fleam is a young girl in Saudi Arabia
and the lesson is about how wonderful it
is to be a young girl in Saudi Arabia
hello and how wonderful it is polygamy
is and how wonderful it is to be the
second wife because the first wife she
has to do all the dinners she has to go
around socially and she's not a
cleanness not a social girl and how
great that she doesn't have to do it and
she could be stay-at-home wife and she
goes on to say that she loves the burqa
and she feels sorry for all those quote
horribly and modestly dressed Western
women and the last line of this lesson
in the public school of Georgia is how
fortunate we are to have the Sharia now
understand something I know how I'm
painted I know I'm painted as a racist
Islamophobic anti-muslim bigot
I know that if you talk about this even
this much this not the racist
Islamophobic anti-muslim Vega - why
because because this is the way they
silenced anybody that speaks to this
issue this is the way they enforce the
blasphemy laws of the Sharia in this
country the media refuses to touch this
subject in Muslim countries blasphemers
anyone who offends Islam
anyone who insults Islam anyone who
criticizes Islam is put to death here in
the West Europe Canada and the US
your character is assassinated you are
demonized you are marginalized you're a
rendered radioactive you are canceled at
a small hotel in a small Texas town
regularly you must be aware of what is
happening to you has it have any of you
been to Europe lately you want a
cautionary tale look to Europe this is
not anti-muslim I speak for all human
beings including Muslims especially
Muslims who fled Sharia who fled Muslim
countries to escape the most oppressive
and radical ideology on the face of the
earth who speaks for them do you ever
hear from them do you ever hear from
them in the media does PBS ever do a
special when a young Christian convert
out of Islam teenage girl left Islam and
was afraid to tell her family but was
outed by Hamas the Noor mosque in Ohio
who was spying on her told her parents
that she had converted out of Islam and
a father threatened to kill her so she
ran away and I remember when I first got
the story because some people in Ohio
sent me the story and they're like they
moved from her friends said we're
worried about her because she converted
out of Islam so I remember saying to
Spencer I said you think she's alive you
think she got out he said they never get
out so imagine my joy really when she
was found in Florida and what ensued was
this case to bring this girl back to
this deadly household she was painted as
some radical crazy Christian
fundamentalist it was disgusting she was
a young sweet girl
virtuous straight-a student meanwhile
millions of girls run away they had
doing drugs they're selling their bodies
nobody's looking for them but this girl
the sweet little virgin straight-a
student
maybe the whole country is looking for
well they dragged her back they did drag
her back to Florida I mean they did
drive it back to Ohio and mind you while
I was in Florida I would see these buses
these bus ads I'm sure you've seen them
in Texas why Aslam come to Islam
proselytize him for a slum and I saw
these buses and I said what about those
that want to leave Islam so I sought an
ad campaign I took their ad and I said
leaving Islam is your family threatening
you is there a fatwa on your head I've
got a refuge from Islam calm well let me
tell you yeah that's right they need
help they need help but there's no
network for them they need safe houses
and it's not just like a that's a young
a wife that's beaten needs to escape a
husband here many times they need to
escape not just their families but the
mosque in the community they need help
nobody speaks for them and when they do
come out like a replica Barry
they're completely destroyed in the
media completely no need are weecha
former Muslim Rafa Sultana former Muslim
even work a former Muslim systematically
destroyed their voices I never heard on
college campuses and of course that
became a story to the bus ads became a
story because it was offensive to
Muslims
I said how was it offensive to Muslims
if I did an ad for housewives that were
beaten it's like all the husband's
saying hey I'm offended
am I wrong when they say that I paint
all Muslims with a broad brush it's not
true
first of all excuse me but I don't have
to congratulate somebody for not wanting
to kill me
I expect that that's my bar but clearly
there's a problem with this ideology
there have been over 18,000 Islamic
attacks since 9/11 each one with the
infra mater of a Muslim cleric each one
with a mosque behind it but nobody will
talk about that the whole jihad against
Israel if you've read the Quran you know
what's Islamic Chu hatred it's part of
the DNA of Islam and this whole
narrative of demonizing this tiny little
state 9 miles at its wide surrounded by
these ginormous Muslim lands and it's
about land you can't make these lies up
they're so big and impossible to believe
the very existence of Israel is an
attack on Muslims it is an attack on
Islam they will never let Israel exist
never let Israel live in peace ever they
did it before 67 they did it before
there was the establishment of the State
of Israel in 1948 there were Palestinian
Muslims there were Palestinian Jews
living in Palestine which is a word that
the Romans conjured up to Hugh milli 8
Israel to humiliate the Jewish people
they changed it to Palestine but the
mufti of Jerusalem the leader of the
Muslim the leader of the Muslim world
was conducting programs against the
Jewish people in 21 29 36 and then he
hooked up with Hitler and he lived in
Berlin from 1941 to 1945 he raised
Muslim armies in Bosnia and was
responsible for the death of 400,000
women Jewish women and children are your
children taught about the role of Islam
during the Holocaust
and the Showa no they are not certainly
the Nazis have been demonized and
vilified so why do they get a free pass
why is the history books whitewashed why
because it's the Sharia do not offend
Islam do not insult Islam even if it's
the truth my friend haired builders was
put on trial in the Netherlands for hate
speech for his short film fitna which is
just a small two short documentary on
the terrorist attack and what inspired
them 9/11 311 77 and he was on trial for
hate speech and the crime was it doesn't
matter according to the Dutch Criminal
Court they said it doesn't matter if
you're telling the truth what matters is
against the law what law is Sharia who's
enforcing the Sharia is this accidental
it's not accidental at the UN the
largest bloc of countries is the
Organization of Islamic Cooperation
previously called the organisation of
Islamic Conference they are 56 countries
plus the Palestinian Authority 56
countries that vote as one block and
they have one objective and that is to
install the Sharia across the world they
are the modern-day universal Caliphate
builders was put on trial because of the
OIC mandates they are very powerful in
the UN they are very powerful me you and
here you had the president United States
President Barack Hussein Obama skulls
sponsoring a resolution at the UN to
restrict free speech it's unbelievable
and the media tells you nothing the
media he has no evil see no evil speak
no evil and how deeply we've been
infiltrated when you have a pentagon
when you have a Department of Defense
issue a final report on the Fort Hood
jihadi a devout Muslim who came out on
Grand Rounds made a PowerPoint
presentation on Grand Rounds that sews
extinct I use it sometimes who is
wearing the garb of the Shaheed the
morning of his jihad who was screaming
Allah Akbar which means Allah
greater greater than what greater than
your God it's supremacist Allah is
greater was giving our currents the
morning of his jihad had soldier of
Allah on his business card said soldier
of Allah and nowhere in the in the DoD's
report today mention religious
motivation how long do you think that
you're going to avoid the inevitable in
this operation fetal position the
Department of Justice is creating whole
Muslim majority legislative districts
for voting based on the racial paradigm
they created for districting districting
based on race do you know about that
the Department of Justice scuttled the
prosecution's of the three hundred
groups names in the largest terrorist
funding trial in our nation's history
the Holy Land trial groups Muslim
Brotherhood groups who according to an
internal CAPTCHA document entered into
that case the stated goal is to
eliminate and destroy Western
civilization from within and sabotage
it's miserable house so that Allah is
victorious their stated goal their words
and instead the Department of Justice
Sue's a school district who didn't allow
a teacher a new teacher a probationary
teacher the only math lab teacher on
their staff to go on Hajj she wanted to
take a month off they said you can't
you're our only math lab teacher well
hold her sued the school by the way they
settled she gets 75 K plus legal
expenses this is happening every day
this is happening every day there's no
hate here listen I'm a lover why don't
why am i doing this why do I subject
myself to this I do it for art for music
for love and for freedom because I love
this country because I grew up so
completely and utterly freedom when I
was a kid
used to say to each other it's a free
country isn't it it's a free country you
don't hear that anymore because it's
inherently not and I do see an leftist
Islamic Alliance and clearly Muslims are
welcome here
this idea of anti-muslim backlash
another deception another lie according
to the recent most recent stats from the
FBI anti-muslim crime is down to its
lowest levels since 9/11 anti-semitic
crime is at historic worldwide levels
you ever hear about that no but they're
constantly every time there's a
terrorist attack what's the knee-jerk
reaction anti-muslim booing do some
backlash no no people die can we talk
about that please this is a war in a
battle of information and the media is
complicit the media is dangerous and
that's why each one of you is so
critical in this book I whatever your
issue is each one of you has a different
issue some of you may not have an issue
that's ok too but if you are fighting
for example we fought the Ground Zero
mosque we fought the Ground Zero mosque
and we won oh yeah
and for those of you that say well you
know what's the big deal let me tell you
what the big deal was a 15-story mega
mosque in a building that was destroyed
in those attacks when the landing gear
crashed through the roof is Ground Zero
that mega mosque 15 story by the name of
Cordoba another I never liked another
stab in the eye
Kodama is iconic of Islamic conquest
over the West when in 711 Muslim armies
invaded Spain which was a collection of
Christian kingdoms and maybe it was a
golden era for the Muslims but it wasn't
a golden era for the Christians and the
Jews that lived on the dhimmitude were
denied basic human rights and was the
site of the very first Jewish program
and the second Jewish program that's the
name of the Ground Zero mosque and let
me tell you something else that has
never been in the history of Islam a
mosque of reconciliation and healing
built on a site of a jihadi attack but
we have tens of thousands of examples of
Islamic supremacists mosques triumphal
mosques built on the cherished sites of
conquered lands the most obvious of
course is the first temple this is and
the second temple the Dome of the rock
the st. Sophia the most exquisite and
extraordinary extraordinary Church in
history is a mosque that should be a
church give that back
give that back and tens of thousands of
Hindu temples tens of thousands of Hindu
temples so you're going to tell me that
a 15-story mega mosque looking down on
the sacred ground that was covered in
blood and ash is reconciliation and
healing and even if they didn't know
let's just say they know now just
because you can build something doesn't
mean you should and even look at the
Pope when they were going to build a
church across from Auschwitz and this
caused an enormous amount of a grief the
Pope would do the church did he have to
know its decency it's human compassion
where's the reciprocity we're constantly
being schooled about this
hypersensitivity in the Muslim world
do not offend Aslam do not run the
Danish cartoons and no media rainbows
Danish cartoons and then when South Park
did an episode where they put Mohammed
in a huggie bear costume because you
can't show Mohammed they got there was a
flat swell on their head and Comedy
Central bleeped out the word Mohammed
have we lost our collective minds gets
better so now a little girl in Seattle
young probably liberal it was a
cartoonist
she loves the show Comedy Central loves
to show South Park she says well led to
everybody draw Mohammed a I guess she
was thinking they can't kill us all and
within 24 hours she's got a fatwa on her
head
now she was clearly out of her element
she didn't know what she was doing so
she would track with what she retracted
never ever retract the smell of weakness
is like blood to sharks not only did the
FBI insist that she go into witness
protection this cartoon is how to give
up her name her job her home at her own
expense and I'm going to ask you how
many here have ever heard of Molly
Norris
one hand she should be the poster girl
for free speech she should be on the
front page of every newspaper in America
and you haven't even heard of her
it's outrageous it is outrageous the
reason why I wrote this book is because
you can fight if you look at the Ground
Zero mosque you had the president
supporting it you not only had a mayor
who vocally supported it in the most the
scariest most clueless way if we don't
build a mosque the terrorists will win
what
it would have been Mecca on the Hudson
that's what that would have been back on
the Hudson
you know when they find these jackets
the we've been getting you know the
Hezbollah has been using the NACO
transit routes well you should know that
they're not go transit routes in tuk in
Mexico why do you think you're seeing an
increase in beheaded decapitations what
do you think that's coming from that's a
religious that's a religious ritual
slaughter you were not it you didn't
have that in Mexico before even this
this latest attack the Iranian attack on
on the Saudis and Israel interesting
that's a very interesting F some people
say modern understand that let me tell
you what that was all about
there's an ugly listen the Islamic world
the Islamic supremacists world sees
senses the vacuum there's a vacuum
because America's abdicated her role
under this president he's relinquishing
American sovereignty is in my book my
first book the post American presidency
the Obama administration's war on
America I outlined his abdication of
American hegemony evil loves a vacuum so
there's always this constant battle in
Islam between the Shia and the Sunni so
the very idea that Iran which is the
leader of the shield world would execute
the Saudi ambassador on American soil
their number-one patron and Ally and
blow up the embassy and of course the
Jews too because it's not a party if you
don't kill the Jews would be a huge
message a loud message to the world of
supremacy and domination and again I
applaud the thwarted attacks how many
attacks have we had in this country and
what bothers me is that just because
they don't get get it off doesn't mean
it wasn't serious this some kind of a
disconnect there's some kind of a
disconnect we're constantly thwarting
Islamic attacks and you're not allowed
you not allowed to say the word jihad if
you ask anybody on the street what we'll
be doing who will be fighting in Iraq
and Afghanistan they can't answer you
it's very simple it's G
that's it it's not complicated and Obama
partnering with the Taliban he it's
shocking
they're gassing girls schools that we're
building guessing them and where are the
liberals where the left what I mean when
I see when I go to these anti-israel
rallies and I see queers for Palestine I
got it I am still stunned by that you
don't they do to quiz in Palestine they
take a razor all around the face and
they pull the face off you know what
they do to gays in Iran they hang them
in the public square but on cherry
pickers and leave them that Iraq so that
you get the message and we are aware and
we're aware the left incredible to me
that the left would shut down the
liberals which again another word that's
been completely inverted every word
means the opposite of what it means
occupation Chicago is holding a peaceful
protest okay
peaceful protests with a calling for the
destruction of Israel and Obama's power
by Sheikh Khalid he is speaking a
virulent notorious Jew hater and insider
of to genocide and again I have to say
you know I I don't get it
where what why is in America asking
Obama why was sending troops into Africa
Africa they're slaughtering Christians
in Egypt by your hand by your hand
because Obama had invited the Muslim
Brotherhood to his speech in Cairo in
June of 2009 four months five months
after he took office
they were outlawed Sheikh Qaradawi was
outlawed there was a reason I'm sorry I
don't think Mubarak was the bad guy that
everyone painted about to be perfect
hardly am I going to show them not but
there are degrees he was the only u.s.
allied Muslim country to make a peace
with Israel and you may not have liked
it
but it's done it's
it's stuck when I was in Israel
dedicating a grove of trees to the
victims of honor killings worldwide they
were shelling Israel from Egypt first
time in 30 years have you heard about
that the 30 Christians that were
slaughtered last week 300 hurt send some
troops I don't believe in sending troops
by the way unless it's a matter of
national security
I don't know what we're doing in Africa
I don't know what we're doing in Libya
what we're doing in Libya you know what
Libya is now Libby's falling into the
hands of al Qaeda and jihadists is
Qaddafi a good guy he'll know is al
Qaeda and jihad better worse worse there
are degrees there are degrees of damage
there are degrees of evil you explain to
me his foreign policy he saw it with the
enemy every time and it's not just Obama
we have been infiltrated what I hear
that Heidi T's in the audience is going
to be running for office I say Baruch
Hashem this is what we need to do you
need to get politicians in office who
get it allow your pants Hannah was
running I don't care if you don't live
it HeLa is enough Caroline to send him
money
he gets it I I have to tell you that
there's no way you can escape this issue
and the more you avoid it it's like
you're supposed to play a tennis match
and you don't show up what do you think
the match didn't happen no you forfeited
the game that's what's happening the
fact that we protested that mosque and
we would not let up and how do we get
the word out how did I get 40,000 people
to Ground Zero on September 11th let me
tell you something I've been writing
that story since November 2000 2010 you
did it you made that the number-one
story of 2010 and the number one
international story of 2010 the media
wouldn't touch that story but everybody
kept sending around these little stories
that it would be the fans are my crew my
squad and then my first rally which I
expected a couple hundred people and we
got like 8,000 people somebody took a
post of mine and just took the pictures
to a link text nothing just the pitches
up against the mosque
and that email went viral I was getting
my own pictures hey did you see this
like 20 times a day and that's when the
media woke up so do not think for one
second that what you do is not important
do not believe for one second that the
individual can change the course of
human events because the individual can
and does and will change the course of
human events this is a unique and
brilliant and magnificent experiment
America in human history oh it really is
we're in it so we can't really see the
beauty of it but America is the first
moral government in the history of man
based on individual rights yes it
deserves
the first and everything noble and
brilliant and magnificent we achieved
was a logical fidelity to that principle
that's what I'm fighting for
I'm not fighting against anything I will
oppose anyone that dares to take my
freedom I will not live for the sake of
another man and I will not ask another
man to live for the sake of me and it's
important that you get involved in this
fight you say how well I will tell you
how I'm glad you asked me that question
when you wake up in the morning and you
rub the sleep from your eyes you first
thing you ask yourself what am I going
to do today to save the Republic I don't
care if it's just sending an article
around when you throw that little pebble
in the water you set it around she sends
it around he sends it around that's it
we are our own media we are the media of
one and I know it's difficult and I know
it's a leapfrog
and I know listen you see the Muslim
Brotherhood groups are actually getting
the FBI to stop talking to anyone
critical of Islam
no matter how heralded the scholar from
even warrick you know to Robert Spencer
so they what is this and then in the
schools when your children are taught
that curriculum you are disarming the
children you are disarming law
enforcement and it's ball comes down to
you it doesn't have to be this way it's
certainly winnable you will not like
what comes after America you won't so I
left some time for question and answers
there is so much more that I could tell
you I like I didn't even discuss the
litigation jihad like the ten million
dollar lawsuit that was filed against me
by Griffey Barry's parents attorney the
Christian convert I told you about that
escaped I was a very big public attitude
advocate for her ten million dollar
lawsuit and if David you shell me and
Robert Muse of the Robert Moore Law
Center send those guys a check didn't
represent me pro bono over three hundred
and fifty thousand dollars in legal fees
he dropped the case because there was no
case and the two didn't did the judge
what I mean there were LT was total
freedom of speech it was a total freedom
of speech issue I had filed a motion to
yes they never ruled on it they never
ruled on it
you must be proactive right now in the
New York subway system they are running
ads that call for the end of US aid to
Israel there are anti-semitic outs there
clearly anti-semitic ads as if the year
the US aid is somehow an impediment to
peace again the big you know Hitler
called it the big lie
tell the big lie often or not that
becomes the truth so I submitted my ads
this was my ad was one line of text in
any war between the civilized man and
the savage side with the civilized man
support Israel defeat jihad
yeah they rejected my ax I'm suing
that's true I am I'm suing so so yeah so
you need to understand you're not bad
for loving good because that's what it
is it's the hatred of the good for being
the good you're not bad for do not let
them shut you up this is the key the key
is shutting people up read the Quran and
don't buy a whitewashed version the
closest version in English is Dawood da
WOD Penguin Books read it for yourself
but every time they cite Quranic chapter
and verse every time they blowing
themselves up that they're not all
misunderstandings of Islam I assure you
the reason why I wrote the book is you
do need to know how to fight the fight
it's it's it's difficult you know the
media is your enemy so when you're doing
these things if they talk to you outside
they're looking to get you to say one
thing that they can parse and then paint
the whole well your Tea Party do I have
to tell you how they demeaned and wide
and libeled and defamed this movement of
righteous people
I know I've spoken at enough tea parties
to know that you will save America oh
yes and how they're clamming up this
movement in wall street you should see I
live there you should see it is vile
the signs are vile they are attacking
the police and then when the police go
to push them back that's the shot you
see on the front page of the New York
Times trust me on this if the first of
all there have been 1500 arrests right
trust me it should be ten thousand
they're not arresting them they're
getting away with such lawlessness if
any of you guys did 1/10 of what they
were doing you'd all be in jail they're
getting this they really are and now
they're Muro marauding mobs all over the
city they've gone from Times Square next
they're going to do and and it's
interesting listen I wasn't too unhappy
because the kadhi park withdrew my
permit
my Ground Zero mosque rally on June 6
d-day yeah but they were true it now let
me see them why people they leave the
place clean up than when they got there
you could eat off the street okay
now that same Park that said well know
were the only reason which were drawing
it is because you know we don't want to
get involved in politics that's where
these dregs have set up home and I say
drugs they are the most beautiful like
flower pots that a marble destroyed I
mean they destroyed this Park oh yeah oh
yeah so be careful be careful how and
that's why I want to say to high it you
know be careful who you side with
because that's going to come back to
bite you the left to the left thinks why
does the left love this I know why the
left loves this first because the left
always aligns itself with whatever
totalitarian ideology there is of the
day if it wasn't Stalinism it was
communist with wasn't communism it was a
National Socialist Workers Party whose
the National Socialist Workers Party the
Nazi Party they say it was a right-wing
no it wasn't it was left and now this
the Sharia is the ultimate weapon in
which to control the people the ultimate
weapon that's why I think they like it
the restriction of free speech the love
loves to shut us up so they use that
they don't believe me they will be eaten
alive they have no idea they think they
I know what they're thinking they think
look we'll just use these we'll use
these tools they are the ones that are
being used just look at Europe Europe
has no-go zones the police cannot enter
firefighters cannot enter unless there's
a staged incident where it's staged to
lure the police in attack the police
brutally attack the police and that's
how they get the message across and if
you go into these towns if you drive
through tall men on the street women are
covered from soup to nuts like that Kim
Kardashian wearing a burqa in Dubai I
ask you know let me tell you why it's so
incredibly reprehensible she's an
Armenian she's an Armenian now the mufti
of Jerusalem who I told you about the
leader of the Muslim world that you know
was responsible for the death of
hundreds of thousands of Jews you know
what he kind of
he was an officer in the Ottoman Empire
the Ottoman Ottoman army he cut his
teeth at the Armenian Genocide which
resulted as you know in the death of two
million Armenian Christians so I urge
you to do your homework I urge you to
talk to your kids there are no young
people here they're like this mindless
generation of Bath's not all not all I
see young here yeah look one mm I know I
know I love you because it takes
incredible courage for you to be here it
takes incredible it cannot be easy and I
think they are attracted to this
movement because this is like their
Woodstock you know like when I was a kid
we'd go see Stevie Wonder you know they
were great you know music festivals what
do they have lady Google what do they
have I do what I have and that's what I
haven't here for music I mean I like
something it's not a generational thing
there's no music it's mom bump bump bump
bump I mean it there's no music so this
is like become they're down there
they're making love they're down there
they're smoking pot and they're being
used ill used in the work now of course
it's now they want all college students
to occupy college campuses take over
college campuses and they have their
list of demands this is not going away
this is not going to be pretty this is
going to get ugly
this is Obama's way of shifting the
blame of incurring more debt than all
the previous presidents combined routing
the American economy shifting the blame
to the businessman again the big giant
light let's blame business for business
it's the demonization of a successful
and the exaltation of failure that's
what you're witnessing here it is the
opposite of America the opposite of
America this class warfare is ugly and
divisive and it's going to get uglier
and you're going to see that the enemy
of my enemy is my friends are you going
to see the aligning of Islamic groups
with left-wing groups and it's going to
get very ugly and I'm telling you
there's no such thing as being a passive
bystander because you will be collateral
damage and when you go to sleep at night
and you think about your children okay
put some money where
my children I have an insurance policy
oh no damn future is so dim at this
moment I am not engaging in hyperbole
it's up to us I want to thank you very
much for coming out
I want to thank you very much for
suffering the slings and arrows of the
asshats outside and III pray I pray that
you continue the fight
you